good evening Stuart brand from the long
now foundation I usually come up here
with some sense of what I'm gonna say
but I've been a deep conversation with
our speaker backstage and we're doing
what people of our generation do which
is reminisce there's a game out there
called passages you can play on your
iPhone or other smartphones and it's a
game that it's just one person sometimes
two people marching through its kind of
obstacles for five minutes it's a
five-minute game it's never shorter than
that it's never longer than that and
goes along and paints points are
collecting points are collecting and
I'll tell you the punchline right now
which is that the little creature is
walking along alone you can see it
gradually getting bald-headed and
white-haired and things like that
walking a little slower and at five
minutes it turns into a gravestone
that's it that's the game
what want to play again and one of the
wonderful details you notice about it is
at the beginning there's a kind of a
play space at bar of obstacles you know
when you start out this little fresh
thing popping along it's all in front of
it and halfway through the game of two
and a half minutes right in the middle
and toward the end of the game it has
gotten over to the right end and of the
thing and so it has less notice about
the obstacles is running into but
there's fewer of them and you realize
that that's part of the peculiarity of
having a lifespan with a beginning a
middle and an end is the beginning
everything's out in front of you and at
the end what you can see most of is
what's behind you and so Mary Katherine
and I have been there reminiscing
because that's what we're good at by now
the question long now question is who
what we know what young people bring to
the future so the future is a big event
for them it's this whole huge thing has
got climate change in or who knows what
old people have is a different
perspective on the future which has got
all of this personal backlog that is
framing how they think about the future
now now is that framing wisdom Mary
Katherine basin is here to tell us
wotcher good evening you have to let me
hear you I can't see you the lights are
so strong I needed a good strong
response from you I can hang on to the
conviction that you really are there for
the next however many minutes I live in
a shorter now than Stewart I'm
interested in human life spans
generations and how they fit together
the stages of lives and how knowledge
has passed on from generation to
generation so I'm really not up to the
ten thousand year thing except a notice
10,000 years back is the Neolithic
Revolution we don't know what 10,000
years ahead is going to be but what we
do know is that the shape of lives is
changing now in our time and that maybe
those changes that are taking place have
some promise for solving the problems
that lie ahead of us that's what I'm
hoping for
I was remembering this morning
as I thought about this talk
conversation I had with with another
woman who was just a little older than
me I was in my 20s and she by the time
we were having this conversation she was
divorced and she was too
think about how she felt the day before
her wedding and she described a
conversation she had with her mother and
her mother had had rather a wild youth
in the Roaring Twenties and she said to
her mother she just wasn't sure that she
was ready to get married and she didn't
know what the future would be but she
said it's just so long and her mother
said what's the matter does his penis
frighten you
no the future frightened her going off
to this ceremony and talking about
forever till death do us part
with some justice if you've ever walked
through a colonial graveyard nowhere in
California next time you're in New
England walk through some graveyards and
there you will find all of these graves
of people well especially women who died
in childbirth
a man might have four or five wives one
after the other who died until finally
she outlives him and it says you know
all the others our beloved wife of
Ebenezer and then there she is
relict of Ebenezer a little known fact
is that marriages last longer in the
United States today on average than the
they did in the colonial era
see we're using divorce as a substitute
for death
we've added 30 years to life expectancy
in the last century through most of
human history average life expectancy at
birth was a bit over 30 years time
enough to have a couple of kids and it
still is that low in the poorest regions
of the planet and here we are in the
United States by no means the
longest-lived country but creeping up on
an average life expectancy of 80 we're
not quite there yet more than double
what it has been through most of human
history
it's so long we go on being grownups
year after year after year to dramatize
this for you I want you to think for a
minute about human childhood you know
we're an awfully inefficient species
most other mammals are ready to
reproduce within a year after they're
born they're walking within a matter of
hours and some of the small ones are
even faster we're not capable of
reproducing for 10 to 15 years and we're
not even independent then right our
children don't go off and look after
themselves and leave home they're coming
back until they're 30 and 35 and there
would be so much more efficient if we
were born with a set of an eight
programs that allowed us to go off and
forage and look after ourselves without
all of this long dependent human
childhood
it's a lot of work but this long
dependent human childhood is what makes
our distinctive adaptation possible it
makes us a species that has been able to
adapt to conditions everywhere on the
planet able to accumulate knowledge plan
ahead record knowledge pass it on makes
us the time-binding species in terms of
awareness of the past and ability to
project into the future and let it be
said it's also this long period of
dependent childhood that makes us
capable of love capable of hope
conscious of persistence
I want you to imagine for a moment the
possibility that the increased longevity
that has been produced largely by
technology public health things of that
sort may make a difference for the human
species as momentous as the evolution of
our long dependent childhood
in fact I would argue that within the
last 50 years or so a new stage of
adulthood
has emerged it's a combination of
culture and technology because we've
still got a lot of the cultural baggage
that says you're getting old at 50 or 60
or whatever the retirement as an
institution with a pension was basically
invented right around the turn of the
20th century was first set at age 70 by
Bismarck in the building of the civil
service for unified Germany and if you'd
worked all your life in the civil
service you could retire with a pension
at 70 and I want to tell you they didn't
spend a lot of money on those pensions
and you certainly couldn't wouldn't have
been likely to be able to keep a job
after 70 and you didn't keep the pension
for very long if you actually collected
it and a few years later they moved it
down to 65 we've increased longevity by
30 years since they said it at 65 and
people still refer to that as
traditional retirement age
and as you as you know many European
countries are now having economic
difficulties many in many places
there's mandatory retirement at 50
that's when the ARP sends out that
letter my theory is that that the reason
so many European countries have set
retirement and made it mandatory in that
way is because they all remember the
rise of fascism and the effect on a
society of having large numbers of
unemployed young people in any case in
this country we don't have mandatory
retirement more and more people are
working longer but the interesting thing
is I'm sure that everyone in this room
has had conversations in which somebody
said I'm 60 or 70 or 80 or 90 but I
don't feel 60 or 70 or 80 or 90 all
right and basically what that bit of
conversation means is a long time ago 30
40 years ago I internalized a set of
stereotypes about what it would be like
to be 50 60 70 80 whatever that is and
now I've lived that number of years on
the planet and I don't feel the way I
expected to feel
Chris I may look at other people my age
and figured they're old I know right and
you've all heard this business about
sixties the new 40 all right I want to
tell you if you've passed 40 you're
never gonna see 40 again it reminds me
of when I was in my 20s and they said
you can have it all remember that women
could have it all well you can't you
balance things off and you work out a
way to have what is important to you in
a responsible way
but what these phrases that people use
and it's it's all through the press what
they really mean is that people are
reaching these ages it isn't just that
we're living longer we're living
healthier we're able to do far more for
a longer period of time and for 60
you're not going to be 40 again but
you're able to do many things that you
didn't imagine you would be able to do
with that age and we now have a society
you know it used to be through most of
human history if you were fortunate you
knew one grandparent most people I think
probably got to know one grandparent for
a while anyhow and a few know more and
most people who had children who live to
reproduce got to see at least one
grandchild well nowadays there are
children with seven or eight
grandparents
now that's counting the for biological
grandparents and the exes
and a couple of great-grandparents and a
few honoraries and they're not behaving
themselves and not sitting around making
their laps available for children they
are starting new careers going back to
school and getting new degrees going on
around the world cruises and eloping
scandalizing their children and
grandchildren and having a lot of fun
now we
use our own lives as measuring devices
in various ways we use our families for
thinking about communities making
metaphors of relationship what does it
mean to say we're all sisters and
brothers we're taking a metaphor from
the family when we think of the future
like my friend for whom the future was
terrifyingly long the married future and
we think of our own past and those
metaphors are all shifting as we move
into the society with far more people
living longer so we're becoming a four
generation society a society in which
there are children not yet adult say up
to about 35 and adults the parents and
grandparents and great-grandparents
it's worth asking the Darwinian question
are we increasing our fitness as a
species by living longer there is some
very good evidence that we are that
among species social species that live
in groups herds flocks the presence of
post-reproductive adults with long
memories increases the inclusive fitness
of the entire flock herd whatever that
there's an adaptive value to have as
long as memory is possible to have some
members of the community of the breeding
population with longer memories
but we're gonna have to change the way
our metaphors work with our grandparents
behaving differently running around the
way they are you know I used to talk
about those posters you all know we we
have Stuart brand to thank for the
availability of some of those images of
Earth has seen from the moon there used
to be posters that said your mother love
her or leave her well I think that does
work in some parts of the world but in
the United States you know what you do
with mothers you leave them the poster
speaks to a set of attitudes about time
and kinship and relationship in this
country it doesn't say love her it says
leave her there was a brief period when
people thought well we would all go to
another star and that would be fine and
at that point I started making a
slightly different argument instead of
thinking of the planet as our mother
which many
societies have done what if we were to
start thinking of the planet that we
inhabit as we would think of a child
because like a child the planet will be
here when we are all gone the future is
unknown we can't control it my mother
used to say the only thing you can be
really proud of as a parent is that you
have not damaged your child too much
well we're not doing that well with the
planet but it struck me as I planned
what I'd talk about today
one of the things I've been very
interested in is what people learn as
adults continuing lifelong learning and
what are the circumstances that force
people to learn intensively as adults or
the draw them to learn intensively
adults so I've looked at what happens to
refugees or what happens to people who
develop a disability what happens in
religious conversions what happens to
immigrants who have to learn to live in
a totally different cultural environment
and it struck me that one of the most
intensive learning experiences in the
lives of adults is the birth of a first
child you know we're not equipped by
instinct to know how to look after a
child we read books we go to classes we
look up Spock they coach you a little
bit before you take the baby home and
then we have to not only learn to care
for that child but keep relearning how
to care for that child who is changing
from week to week
and here's short of sleep and if the
mothers breastfeeding her breasts hurt
and your sex life is disrupted and your
social life is disrupted and for the
next 20 odd years you're going to have
to plan your life in relation to that
and subsequent children and on the whole
we're glad we did we you know you got to
ignorant self-centered adults that have
to learn to be decent parents most of
the teaching is done by the newborn
actually
and it affects every aspect of life as
learning to the extent that we do to
mitigate climate change to adapt to the
events that it's going to bring to deal
totally differently with energy with
resources with the International strains
and conflicts that are going to result
from decreasing assets decreasing arable
land she it wouldn't hurt if we started
thinking of the earth as a child were
responsible for instead of a mother that
we can rely on to care for us and keep
giving
so what we're doing we're changing the
shape of lives and the relationship
between generations the way we think of
time and the way we think of space it
struck me as I thought about this phrase
the long now which was coined by Brian
Eno that it exactly parallels the phrase
that Seward coined back for the
publication of the first Whole Earth
Catalog that the whole earth is a way of
saying the whole here it's parallel to
the long now
mystics and spiritual teachers talk
about being in the present how big is
the present how long is now being in the
here and now how large is the here that
we live in how long is the now of our
present moment a once heard a city
planner going through the stages of the
life cycle in terms of changes of
mobility with mobility the infant in his
mother's arms very little capacity for
mobility was gonna learn to crawl find
its way around the living room at a
certain age that child will be out in
the street going to a neighbor's yard
and gradually over time here becomes
larger for the individual and many
cultures have institutionalized a period
of travel and wandering but you're in
German was called the von der yar when
you go and travel and then you settle
down and the space that you move around
in in fact contracts a bit when a family
has children that they're looking after
and contracts again if physical
disabilities and weakness come along but
as long as memory is intact wherever we
have traveled is still available and of
course in terms of information we live
in a much much larger here than any
human community has ever lived in before
that includes the entire planet and and
we live in a longer now in terms of our
knowledge of the past than any communing
human community has ever lived in but we
just don't have time to think about the
future and when I think about time what
strikes me
is how incredibly busy adults are in our
society bombarded by information worried
about what's gonna happen next week the
next round of bills the next election
cycle the next quarterly report the next
time when they get a promotion or they
don't or a bonus or they don't
when I started looking at this issue of
longevity and what does it offer us as a
species one of the things that struck me
is that it offers many people who have
not had time or taken time to reflect
the opportunity to reflect for the first
time in their lives
you know as I said I can't see any of
your faces but in the past I've asked
audiences you think you'll be wise when
you get old well I did see a few nods
yeah people say oh yes as if it were
automatic and I'm here to tell you it is
not automatic you can have all sorts of
complex and rich experiences and we all
say experiences the best teacher but
only if you do your homework and the
homework for the teacher called
experience is reflection and we put that
off
and let ourselves be individually and as
a society rushed into short-term
decision-making and we don't give
ourselves the chance to become wise
and just as we know that the
post-reproductive adults and a herd of
deer say contribute to the fitness of
the whole community the presence of
postural reproductive adults who have
reflected on their life's experience
contributes to the inclusive fitness of
human communities this has been fairly
well studied looking at such things as
the the availability of grandparents in
relationship to the survival rate of
infants born into the community and
since I've talked about the problems of
adapting learning how to care for a
child boy is it helpful to have a
grandparent available preferably a
grandparent who knows when to shut up
and what's the balance that you have to
seek but we actually have a very nice
kind of feedback system going where each
generation does some things that are new
and there's an opportunity to compare
them back with the previous generation
test them out a three-generation
structure here's a nice example when I
was a child when I was born the accepted
way to put a child to bed to sleep was
on its back when my daughter was born
the accepted way to put a child in the
crib to sleep was on her tummy it is now
Dogma that you put children down on
their back and it reduces the risk of
sudden infant death syndrome since crib
death now if it was just between me and
my daughter she has she gives birth to a
baby and I made might say put the baby
on his back dear when she said no
nowadays we put the baby to sleep on his
tummy you know they sleep much better if
they don't dive since they sleep much
better on their tummies because it's
much more stable so they wake up more
easily when they're on their backs but
we can have a conversation where I say
this is how my mother did it
and what I did was different
and what you're doing is different from
what I did but isn't it fun that it's
the same thing that was true of what
your grandmother did so that with three
generations and even with four
generations we can learn to look at the
nature of the changes we are making and
think about the process of change in a
way that only this overlapping of
generations will allow
so what we have today
suddenly fairly suddenly is especially
with the retirement of the baby boomers
a wealth of grandparents all giving
advice a lot of people don't think this
is an improvement it's going to bankrupt
Medicare and Social Security and there
are all these useless people around and
we're going to have to change the timing
of the traffic lights heaven knows what
you get slower crossing the street you
know and we haven't yet learned to
benefit as a society from the
availability of grandparents who are
unlike any cohort of grandparents in the
past in terms of their health and
richness of experience and engagement
with the world and you know what we're
telling them we're telling them don't
live in a Sun City and play golf when
politicians speak to seniors they talk
about entitlements the assumption is
that's all they care about Medicare
prescription drug benefits and so on
there's something profoundly demeaning
about that
to say the people who have had busy
productive lives
now you go off in a corner semi
segregated and you don't have to care
about the future honestly you know
they're people who will say it will save
themselves if I talk about climate
change they say ah I'll be dead by then
I don't care
but the reality is that the grandparents
and the great-grandparents and the
uncles and aunts and great uncles and
great aunts are invested in the future
do care about what will happen to the
planet care about the world in which the
children they love as little kids are
going to raise their own children and
what we need to do I deeply believe is
to mobilize that concern bolster it with
the new awareness a new consciousness of
what people can do as they get older
put them to work
get some juice out of them us take
advantage
of having a group of people with some
time for reflection looking forward
looking backwards deciding which changes
make sense which changes don't make
sense I used the term consciousness
because every liberation movement that's
happened in this country has involved
people getting rid of stereotypes that
they internalized and thinking through
what they wanted what was possible what
could change it was true of the civil
rights movement it was true of the
women's movement true of gay liberation
sometimes the rhetoric starts with I
want more for my group equality but then
when the Equality comes you get the
contributions the participation the
engagement back in the 2004 election I
got together I've been meeting with a
group of women all women who'd been
involved in the women's whoo I'm 70 okay
we met for about we've been meeting for
about 10 years in other words we met to
say we fought for the right to work we
fought for the possibility of
participating and taking responsibility
being involved in decisions and now
everybody says don't you want to retire
so we met from all over the country you
know if the names of several you know
Pat Schroeder you may know Ellen Goodman
the columnist a novelist a
psychotherapist an anthropologist Oh
Geri Ferraro
trying to figure out we've been through
this once we've had to rethink our lives
once we've had to get rid of the
stereotypes about women and what women
can and should want in their lives and
what women have to offer by being full
participants in society so what do we
think about retirement so we put
together a project and we called granny
voter and I still have a button it's a
rocking chair
but it's jet-propelled and our motto was
I'm voting for my grandchild he or she
doesn't have the vote and you can still
find this on the Internet
I haven't done a lot since the campaign
of o4 but it's about it's it's granny
voter org
I'm WWE voter org on the internet and
it's just about to be revived because
I'm taking the project which I was
trying to run off my kitchen table and I
don't have a kitchen table I just have a
counter taking the project into a
nonprofit called generations United
because I think the time has come to
look at this large group of people who
have come to a kind of a transition
point in their lives
some have retired in some cases the
children have left home in other cases
they may have lost jobs and quite
deliberately say
that
if we reflect if we work together we can
make the fact that we live longer as
critical as important to maintaining
society as a long childhood is we can
turn the specter of all these expensive
old people into a resource and when we
do that just going to finish now when we
do that I think we're going to look at
the entire lifecycle somewhat
differently we're gonna have to say boy
schools have to be different starting
with nursery school if people are going
to be engaged participants in society
for the next 6070 years with all the
changes going on we're gonna look
differently at careers we're gonna speak
differently about the decision to retire
or not retire we're going to recover the
volunteer force that disappeared when
women went into paid employment couldn't
look differently in marriages to
with the likelihood of both being alive
for a great many years you got to figure
out how you got to keep re learning
relationships as you go along so what
I'm saying is not just about what one
might want to do in one's 50s or 60s or
70s or 80s or 90s it's about having a
society in which we get the full benefit
of the experience and wisdom of people
at all different ages as they continue
to learn and adapt and we take full
advantage of our adaptability as human
beings to learn to live at peace with
our planet
and we get the house lights up a bit so
Murray Katheryn can finally see who's
here actually yeah that mean Hey
well the institutionalization of the
elderly or everybody older than 50 has
been a RP getting that letter and AARP
pretty much is an invitation to
entitlement and not to taking on
responsibilities as near as I can tell
is anybody busting a RP for this and
saying get with the program you know I
don't want to bust the AARP I do because
they've done important work they've
gotten stuck it's been I mean the the
very availability the huge increased for
instance of child care that's being done
by grandparents now the number of people
doing volunteer work many of those
things are possible for them because old
age does not mean penury and because
they're not in panic of the next time I
have to go to the doctor okay so the
structure of benefits that we have is
not something to just throw away okay
it's something to expect to return on
and how do you do and and I don't see
the AARP moving strongly in that
direction there's some of it the gray
Panthers
which didn't survive really in large
numbers the loss of Maggie Kuhn they and
they demised about the same time the
Black Panthers did well but the point is
that the gray Panthers or the raging
grannies against the war in Iraq what
have you were organizations of older
adults for the larger society rather
than for the members for other older
adults and we've got to have a bit of
both I I'm more inclined to try and seed
something and get small groups thinking
through what they want to do and then
maybe you know there are P will also
evolve the small groups cohort does that
tend to be people of an age and of a set
of experience or is it
multi-generational like whole families
that take this on horizontal or vertical
I guess is what is what grouping is most
has highest yield there or is that even
a good question I think at this point in
time
you know the the the odd thing is a lot
of people are making decisions as if
they we're gonna be dead in five years
right and then there are around 4:30
it's a sequence of five-year plans
there's six of them so I think there is
there is a game for older adults talking
this business through and you know we
get a gist - okay right my godmother
went into an assisted living and I'm
visiting her I asked her have you made
some friends since you moved in and she
said to me Oh everyone here is so
deteriorated what she didn't think she
was deteriorated she just thought all
those other people were uh and this is
part of what we have to get beyond if
we're gonna get anything done but but
the alliance between grandparents and
grandchildren is absolutely critical
yeah that's powerful it really is there
because um the war between children and
parents is is genuine and it has to be
fought out sort of week by week
but the ethica and then there's the
piece of that you can make you can a
grandparent as a parent without the
hassle or without the you know the
obligation that sense of having to obey
and all that tough stuff and hence the
value presumably I guess the question is
does that extend it with grandparents
great grandparents and so on or there's
a four generation different than three
generation or is it just more of the
same
I think the great-grandparents
physically their condition resemble
mm-hmm the grandparents in the past
mm-hmm okay
the tricky question however is that in
the past the parent generation was
simultaneously caring for children and
for their parents right that was the
traditional family structure yeah and
that's the developing world has a lot of
that that was great the developing world
is like that at the moment the
grandparents are going off and and going
on around the world tours and the
great-grandparents don't have that quite
that relationship with their
grandchildren so there's a problem there
I mean we're gonna get old we're gonna
get old later and then not all the same
way but the timing is different and the
dynamics are gonna be different and I
can't tell how it's gonna work good
question from Malcolm
how about adulthood three for those of
us passed 75 where physical issues can
cause intermittent quality of life
sometimes you're on and sometimes you're
not you know if you're real lucky if
that doesn't happen till you're how old
I said past 75 you got five years at
Dalton to in so many ways Journal what
it resembles it resembles the
adolescents I mean what happens when
you're a teenager you're an adolescent
well your skin gets all funny it gets
its and your hair doesn't do what you
wanted to do and your body feels
different
and people look at you differently with
different expectations and an adulterer
too is like that everybody is dealing I
figure most people in adulthood to have
had at least one medical event that they
would have died of a generation ago and
often several mm-hmm most everyone in
adulthood too is taking at least one
long-term medication okay there are
already friends who are dying
contemporary used to contemporaries
dying not as many as in the past at
those ages but still and you know you
are discovering limits not just limits
I'm gonna live forever but limits to
energy resilience all of those things
mm-hmm you gotta take that into account
so you worry about the death part is I'm
72 and my cohort these days it feels
like Pickett's Charge you know we're
going up the hill at Gettysburg and I've
done this I actually once got to reenact
Gettysburg with a bunch of other people
and we're all you know open you walk
most of the way up the hill and there's
the guy saying you're dead you're dead
close up Pleasant ranks and there's
fewer and fewer people and then they say
now dead run up the last of the hill and
they're being tap tap tap nobody gets to
the top of the hill well that's life for
us in the 70s is you know Pickett's
Charge and the people around is there's
a few every time we look around and
we're going to funerals and in in so
there's a you do think who cares I'll be
dead or it's a five-year plan at best or
things like that so the mortality the
presence of mortality is not there for
people in their tour
even in the military in Marines as
famous that young Marines discovered
their mortal just about the age of 25
then their behavior changes by the way
where the system works is old men send
young men to die on battlefields because
the young men think they're immortal
right and and that turns out to be a
something you get over and then what so
that the sense of mortality is this part
is that something that reflection then
can work with in a useful way or just
denial a death play out some other
pathologies as it becomes more real well
you know I think the denial of death
that we have in this culture
what it means is that we live a lie for
many years of our life and add to that
the denial of aging you know the dyeing
of hair in the facelifts and and all
that you know maintaining a falsehood
takes a lot of energy I'm gonna die if
you okay I'm gonna die that's good I'm
not in a hurry I'm not gonna rush it
but how terrible it would be if I wasn't
you know one of the things one of the
obligations I would say that goes with
getting older is to do so in a way that
allows the next cohort coming along to
say yeah I'm gonna die eventually - okay
Seymour Gregory died here in San
Francisco he died it's in sad sad Center
and he he'd had cancer and he had been
told he hadn't been told Louis his wife
had been told then he probably wouldn't
live more than a month and he I was in
Iran and he called me up in Iran and
said I have a book I have to finish and
I've got my cancers returned sorry I
have a book I have to finish please come
and help me finish it so I came and we
worked on that was his mind in nature
mm-hmm and I may say that your
foundation put up the money for my fare
forgotten that I had forgotten that and
we finished the book and his cancer went
into remission and I went back to Iran
and he went down to Esalen and lived
there with the cancer in a mission for
the next two years and signed another
book contract
but but then when he started to fail
again and he was in pain and discomfort
he said but this is it I don't want to
be propped up and kept alive I'm going
to go to Zen Center I'm gonna learn how
to let go and die did your being around
that horrify or release or what for you
I'm you so I am failing dying yeah does
that make you easier about your own
eventual failing of dying sure how so
well there were a couple of things it
was for me an immense privilege to be
caring for him and I learned a lot from
that I learned from his acceptance and
the argument that he made and that I've
made sense you know that dying is part
of life okay
I learned a lot from being at Zen Center
at that point meditating on the whole
thing they got your attention
yes got my attention I've you know I've
been with three people through their
death since that time three different
people who made the decision that they
didn't want to be bolstered and put on
machines that they figured their time
was up and that they wanted that the
time of their dying to be a peaceful
reflective time we got cool drugs now
that makes the pain not such a big issue
we we we've even got physicians who were
not worried that one might become
addicted to drugs what if the afterlife
is filled with these dope fiends
[Laughter]
it's okay it's heaven and there's plenty
question from anonymous in our frantic
techno gogo world where youth is adored
and new improved is Holy Writ do you
really think younger people are the
slightest bit interested in what elders
say you know we are a very unusual
country I mean we have more negative
ideas about aging in any other country I
can think oh sorry yeah okay so Iran
what do they do with old people where
well they keep their elders in the home
and look after them and if they
rheumatism hurts them they get them
opium mm-hmm
and they obey them I mean do you want
obedience from your family no I want
however respect as a person not as a
pain in the neck and I have to earn that
I have to keep earning that good but I
wanted to say something else because
I don't think in a society that is
changing rapidly that young people are
going to respect older people unless the
older people are learning as they go
along which is something you have
Marvel's all your life right you're into
new things you're exploring things and
you're saying as I say willing to learn
yeah
you are not what you know or what you
are willing to learn and you're saying
there's this whole huge Kadri of
adulthood to people who are in that mode
you want to learn and I don't think we
support it well I think what would
supporting it well me well when you were
seven did your parents say to you do
what I say Stewart I'm the grown-up I
know best what did they explain thank
you
I think the explaining part came later I
think I was up a generation wears pretty
much I said it's the case and I'll give
you some reasons but they don't really
count you're gonna do it because you're
gonna do it and be spanked otherwise I
get spanked remember that didn't be here
spanked kids they won't admit in public
you know I don't think I was desperately
damaged by being spanked but I don't
think I was particularly improved either
it's one of those you know on their back
on their front kind of deals comes and
goes so what the parts that are
different here's the parts that are
different what I'm saying about
supporting it
however okay is if the message were
human beings can learn all the way
through their lives when you're living
in a rapidly changing society mmm-hmm
you need to make the opportunities to
learn and you need to learn from your
grandchildren there's a lot of that
yeah if you got to play games with the
kids the games they're playing or games
you didn't play when you were young and
so we you'll learn their games and
that's that they're not the slightest
bit interested in the blocks that you
played with it or whatever all right and
then the other major thing that I've
seen is it used to be trust me on this
when kids went away to college they went
away
you saw them at Christmas maybe maybe
Thanksgiving that diminished and then
when they got married and that was
pretty much it
now with email they just it's as if they
just moved down the block they're not
sleeping in the house anymore but
Twitter everything you know about third
grades about their girlfriends and
boyfriends how is that changing
adulthood and grandparents would the
generations have our thanks to just
smartphones are staying connected in a
way they didn't used to do well I'm not
sure what the numbers are now but at one
stage the largest number of people
becoming computer literate and going on
the internet mm-hmm this is the
interesting thing they were learning how
to do it from their grandchildren right
not their children their grandchildren
so they could be in touch with each
other
yep you know one of the things that I do
sometimes if I speak in school I kind of
want I've even spoken that you know
Elementary School's a lot of fun about
is to say well what have you taught your
parents and there's this awful silence
because it's a taboo question they've
been told they're supposed to learn from
older people not teach them your mother
put that out as a program she was quite
worried when my generation was taking
drugs that our parents including her
generation didn't know about and were
worried about and she said when the
younger generation knows more about
something important than the older
generation that is a disruption as
well yeah but look if you keep telling
the children that you know best you know
best you know best they're not going to
tell you about how nice those drugs are
[Laughter]
so what you have to do I'm very serious
about this you have to say teach me
adults have to say you teach me to the
adults have to say teach me ok let's
finish up on the earth as first child
story which is pretty strong and you
know the whole environmentalist approach
to life is that nature's perfect humans
are at best
imperfect all we can do is screw up
nature and you're basically saying no we
are totally responsible for the earth
for nature and this is sort of Marshall
McLuhan's line of after Sputnik there is
no nature only art that we are now in
this situation where basically the whole
world is a as a work of art - yes to
some extent it's got its own history
which is very important we're still
understanding and all of those things
nevertheless in the enthrall scene in
the human modified geological era that
we have created for ourselves we have
this parental responsibility for this
infant earth play that out
we have a capacity we've had a steadily
increasing capacity to disrupt the life
of the planet
apparently accelerating as well as
steadily accelerating and often an
irreversible ways but you know remember
they're they the the Pleistocene
extinctions that may have been
anthropogenic
and we're not we can't get rid of that
capacity to damage this comes as news to
lots of environmentalists but I think
it's true we imagine that we can go back
to the land in the land will not be
changed for being around and it's too
late for that it's too late for that it
really is too late for that
a lot of the climate changes is already
fixed it's set it's moving in that
direction yep buildup of pollutants has
happened already the elimination of
multiple species has happened already ok
we can do some restoration and of course
if we all disappeared some would happen
it was like Pripyat comes back
immediately you know that your noble
turned into the the best wild lands in
Europe as soon as people left more or
less there are some questions about that
but
there's some awfully funny looking
insects there are some arthropods right
close to the reactor that are strange
but they're probably improvements if
we're going to survive on this planet we
have to work out a way of living at
peace with it and at the moment the
damaging initiative is with us and the
caretaking initiative is with us so
we're back to your mother's directive of
the best you can hope for as a parent is
not to damage the child too much yeah
and stay on both sides of that metaphor
for a moment is the main thing to keep
the child out of the street or from
getting a fatal disease as opposed to
just disease azzam down for a weekend
out of school or what is it that is you
know those things are easy to say about
that damaging a child what are some
other aspects of not damaging a child
that might apply to Earthcare the
analogy would be being hit by an
asteroid I mean I don't know prevent
that we can prevent that now with
present technology that one's covered
maybe
okay think of something else it well the
worst one I've heard is that we can be
the next Venus which has no life on it
at all we can lose the whole guy in
apparatus by going too far and then it's
not just a question you know the billion
people left it's of nothing living left
which is the surface of Venus or the
greenhouse effect that is really
reflecting on that there are things
there are things that we can't prevent
like earthquakes or volcanic eruptions
or what-have-you and there are things
that are anthropogenic that we can do
something about at the child that gets
as a disease a communicable disease as
the way when we were growing up our
parents were afraid we'd get polio they
didn't have yeah and to think of that I
was paid a penny a fly to kill flies
because we thought they came from flies
and and I was always hauled off to the
country because you were likely to get
polio if you were in a city because
there were other people there okay I
mean there's only so much you can do
that's not what she has in mind what
what she had in mind when she said they
whether you've damaged a child is is
you've damaged that child by physical
abuse by sexual abuse by depriving that
child of education given that there's a
developmental cycle if you don't learn
to talk at the right time you never will
learn to talk if the child isn't the
eldest that's I think what she has and I
think she took for granted you know that
there are no perfect parents and there
is no there are no adults that don't
have a certain amount of ambivalence
parents have ambivalence too so so it's
okay to feel ambivalence about the earth
as well as somehow make peace with it
[Laughter]
this is a conversation that is going to
go on the rest of Catherine's in my life
which may be a long time and the rest of
everybody's life it is a conversation
which is we assume a ten thousand year
conversation we've just had a few words
in thank you for coming to it this
evening
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you